I’m here at the Ashley-Rakahuri Estuary,
its home to a lot of rare and endangered birds
and it's a very special place for our district.
The Northern Pegasus Bay Bylaw recognises its importance
and while everyone is still able to enjoy its natural beauty
there are rules in place to protect this area.
All visitors need to be careful of the birds and their nesting areas
you should observe from a distance and leave them undisturbed.
Vehicles, dogs, horses and land yachts aren’t allowed in the Estuary
If you’re walking past to get to the beach or on a nearby stopbank
it’s best to keep your dog on its lead.
And let’s leave the airspace to the birds
so no flying microlights, drones or model aircraft above the Estuary.
It’s all common-sense
let’s take care of our birds and their home.
We’ve all got a part to play in preserving our beaches and estuary.